sí
pensé estar más de dos semanas sin puede
abrir los ojos en terapia intensiva en
como prácticamente entre la vida y la
muerte y donde te das cuenta que en
repetidas ocasiones los padres van a
despedir de ti sin saber si sería la
última realmente habría otra oportunidad
de seguir vivo no yo recuerdo que cuando
desperté de platicar a mis padres que
iba a regresar que solamente iban a
pasar los tres días y que regresaría a
la universidad que era lo que tenía por
ahí empezado para mí para mis estudios
profesionales y que bueno se veía posado
por obvias razones no me accidenté con
holístico
yo realmente no entendía lo que pasaba
yo no entendía la magnitud ni el margen
de por ahí desde dificultad en la que me
encontraba pero ahora puedo decir con
toda aceptación y con toda alegría y con
toda confianza también de lo que estoy
diciendo que el no tener dos de mis
piernas
obviamente producto de la pérdida esa
curación sanguínea en ambas piernas a
causa de este accidente automovilístico
es lo mejor que me pudo haber pasado y
es que sencillamente hablémoslo por esta
parte de que ya no tenemos dolor de
rodillas en ningún ningún problema de
ninguna circunstancia ningún día de
nuestra vida en algún futuro y ahora que
incursionamos en esta categoría tan
profesional que es la nascar méxico
sirve es que que realmente hemos estado
luchando tanto también para lograr esto
bueno también estos kilitos de menos que
no tenemos en el cuerpo ahora pegados
van a ser significativamente favorables
para el desarrollo de estas carreras no
el hubiera una palabra tan poderosas y
no sabemos utilizarla yo creo que hay
que saber manejar muy bien esta palabra
porque realmente el futuro no nos sirve
para nada sino más bien para ir adelante
sin repetir las acciones negativas o
complicadas que tuvimos haber tenido en
el pasado
hoy puedo decir que todo tiene un por y
para qué y que inclusive cuando tienes
por ahí una guerra incluso tu mayor
derrota puede convertirse en tu mayor
victoria porque nunca entiendes la
magnitud de bendiciones que están por
venir dentro de ti y delante de ti yo
creo que está esta circunstancia y esta
acción de un giro completamente
cambiante hacia mi vida ha despertado
muchas muchas bendiciones en mi vida de
yo jamás me imaginé la magnitud de
bendiciones que se vendrían delante de
mí mi familia no entendía realmente por
qué no recurría a ayuda profesional
ayuda mental ayuda emocional para poder
pues ahora sí que sobrepasar este
obstáculo esta barrera en contra yo en
ese tiempo no sencillamente se trató de
tres palabras significativas y tres
palabras claves que fueron de mucha
ayuda durante mi proceso durante esta
batalla que tuvimos igualmente también
un sinfín de personas que fueron
guerreros aliados hacia mí para poder
salir de donde estaba y continuar hacia
adelante no englobando simplemente las
tres palabras en la primera que es amar
ama yo creo que siempre puedes amar
siempre hay tiempo para eso y siempre
hay tiempo también para perdonar y
liberarte seguir avanzando nada más amar
yo creo que eso es de lo más importante
también vencer tus sueños yo creo que no
puedes tener más miedo a vivir que morir
no tienes que desaprovechar el presente
pensando en que puede pasar o que van a
decir o qué va a suceder yo recuerdo
inclusive cuando me preparaba por ahí en
tiempo real para comenzar con la con el
ajuste de mis prótesis las prótesis de
robot las prótesis nuevas que no sean
las humanas que tenía previa un
accidente la primera persona con la que
yo me acerco a poder compartir y puedo
tener nuevamente una respuesta favorable
para lo que vendría después dedicada al
mundo de las prótesis y órtesis y que yo
pensaba que por ahí me iba a dar un
aliento de fe y de esperanza por él para
poder salir de donde me encontraba me
sabes que vidal si tú piensas que vas a
volver a caminar prácticamente estás
equivocado y eso sería como ser un
superhéroe algo ficticio y algo que no
va a poder pasar yo creo que si me
hubiera quedado esperando esa respuesta
a toda mi vida y me hubiera concluido
con esa parte no estaría hoy echándole
ganas para
adelante y seguir completando mis sueños
y siempre ir a inspirar más y más
personas no yo creo que hay que hay que
seguir adelante y realmente uno todo lo
puede
la tercera solamente aférrate trata las
cosas para ferraté con bastante fuerza
porque realmente es pieza clave también
para involucrarte en lo que estás
haciendo o sea el tiempo que sea y lo
que estés haciendo y yo creo que también
desde mi vivencia y de mi parte de lo
que estaba haciendo durante el
transcurso de estos años que realmente
son más de cinco años desde que pasó un
accidente me dado cuenta que el cometer
errores a veces puede convertirse
también en una virtud muy buena porque
el error te hace crecer y te hace no
tropezar con la misma piedra y seguir
avanzando nada más aprender de ellos yo
creo que los errores son muy sabios y es
esa las cosas que te pueden pasar para
seguir creciendo y seguir avanzando hoy
en día son cifras exactas 24 mil
personas al año más o menos pierden la
vida por causa de algún accidente vial
vamos el séptimo lugar en el mundo de
accidentes viales lo que significa son
cifras muy muy grandes y muy muy
se puede decir y porque después yo
sabiendo de todo esto que ha pasado de
todas las cosas que han estado
sucediendo y de los datos ahora sí que
tan terroríficos se le podrá llamar de
esa manera he decidido yo regresar a las
pistas a entregarlo todo y a seguir con
este sueño que siempre he tenido
inclusive desde desde niño yo creo que
hay muchas cosas y principalmente la
alegría la felicidad y la adrenalina que
te brindan los coches al estar dentro
del habitáculo cuando el motor
prendiéndolo sintiendo cada parte que
este coche te brinda inclusive las motos
también que siempre he sido fan de todo
lo que todo lo que acelera y todo lo que
son dos o cuatro ruedas es algo
realmente inexplicable hoy en día puede
decir que este año 2021 dejaré un legado
que marcará la historia del autonomismo
mexicano y es que pasó a ser el primer
piloto con discapacidad a nivel nacional
algo que nunca se había hecho en la
historia obviamente esto dejando un
legado también y una apertura y un abre
puertas digámoslo así para más
disciplinas que incorporen las personas
con discapacidad y que cada vez seamos
más inclusivos yo creo que siempre se
puede yo creo que aportando un granito
de arena esto se va a convertir en
benéfico para todas las personas con
discapacidad que tenemos alguna y bueno
incursionamos ahora en la máxima
categoría del automovilismo que como
comentó es la mexico la nascar méxico si
bien este año vamos a darlo todo yo creo
que vamos a seguir avanzando y
continuando para pisar a fondo el
acelerador y sumar buenos puntos ahora
que te platico todo qué es lo que te
hace pensar que no
hoy en día elijo no poner dicen mi
capacidad por quiero yo que realmente
uno lo puede todo pero yo que no hay
nada uno que lo que no puede hacer y
convenciendo al cuerpo con nuestra mente
realmente no todo lo puede hacer uno
tiene la capacidad y la evolución
también de adaptarse a asia hacia este
tipo de circunstancias que puedan
presentarse en la vida y creo que
también es muy asombrosa esta parte de
la evolución del cuerpo de la aceptación
y de la adaptación también no la vida se
escapa de veras que muy rápido se esfuma
y como comentó él el futuro es incierto
así que yo solamente quiero decirles
desde mi vivencia que aprovechemos el
presente que no dejemos para mañana las
cosas que podamos hacer el día de hoy
hay que vivir la vida intensamente y
darle un buen contenido porque nunca
sabemos que puede pasar el día de mañana
hoy tuve la oportunidad de estar vivo
después de como comentó casi tres
semanas de estar en coma repetidas
ocasiones e inclusive siendo católico
recibí la absolución de los pecados para
prepararme básicamente para ir a
descansar a lo que seguía
y ahora puedo decir que solamente queda
romper paradigmas y seguir adelante
porque todo es posible